good afternoon
today i'm going to speak to you about
therapeutic drug monitoring in cancer
chemotherapy and its potential utility
in managing chemotherapeutic drugs uh
for for cancer patients
so when we think about uh therapeutic
drug monitoring or drug management in
general one of the things i wanted to
bring up is that that many drugs are are
dosed in in
somewhat the same way
in that
these are drugs that are
the disease or pathologic condition is
identified um the drugs are dosed
primarily on a milligram per kilogram
basis
and then the the patient is monitored
for a clinical effect or clinical
response um and they would follow this
paradigm called
titrate to clinical effect so you follow
the patient
and then you modify the dose or change
the drug to base it based on the
clinical response and then you repeat
this pattern over and over until
you have either found the right drug or
the right dose or both
but the question we then ask is you know
with the tools we have available is this
is this really always the best way to do
things
so in thinking about therapeutic
monitoring broadly so we want to start
broadly with therapeutic monitoring in
general and then we'll focus it in
on cancer chemotherapy
and we want to think about why do we do
therapeutic drug monitoring in the first
place because we really only monitor a
handful of these drugs
most of the drugs have a strong
correlation between the dose and blood
levels so it's predictive if you you
know that if you give a certain amount
of the drug
then you will get
a certain blood level concentration but
in some cases the blood level can't be
predicted from a dose and there's a lot
of variability we'll talk about
some of those reasons for that and
but because that
relationship isn't
predictable
then measurement of the drug
concentration in the blood is utilized
and it's done for a number of drugs so
in order for tdm to be useful
you know you don't have as we mentioned
the good robust relationship between the
dose of the drug and the blood level but
you do need a direct correlation between
the blood level and the pharmacodynamic
effect whether that's a toxic effect or
whether it's uh the the clinical
response that you want
so if that relationship is there and it
seems like uh that's that's pretty much
common sense right because if you cannot
correlate the blood concentration with
uh with a clinical effect then why do
tdm which is measuring the amount of
drug in the blood in the first place
so
but outside of that relationship then
you also need to have a narrow
well-defined therapeutic interval so
there should be this interval and narrow
is relative to the biologic variability
and
how much the uh the variability and
response is there but this this narrow
well-defined therapeutic there should be
the therapeutic interval is the the
concentration difference between the
minimum effective concentration and the
maximum or the toxic concentration and
if um there is a narrow therapeutic
interval or a well-defined therapeutic
interval then
then that gives you your therapeutic
target range and is useful in therapy
drug monitoring now there are some
exceptions to this
like compliance monitoring there are
some things like
antidepressant drugs or
antiretrovirals for hiv therapy where
perhaps there's not that well-defined
relationship between concentration and
clinical effect but it is known that if
you're not adherent that's poor therapy
and so
maybe you don't have that range but you
have a compliance threshold
and then it's used as an investigative
tool so if you don't see the therapeutic
effect or you see unexpected toxicity
then
having a blood concentration may help
you get to the bottom of this or if you
see changes in drug effects that could
be due to drug drug interactions or
perhaps if somebody's taking a
nutraceutical or some sort of supplement
that may impact that or you can have
physiologic or pathologic changes
and also as we mentioned non-compliance
so in all of these cases drug levels may
help you
may help you manage patient and that
would apply to cancer
chemotherapy as
sometimes maybe you're wondering if
you've selected the drug why you may not
be seeing a response
to that drug in the tumor
another thing to remember about
therapeutic drug monitoring is that
the reference intervals are established
based on clinical studies but not
necessarily
randomized controlled trials so in this
case when we're thinking about
how we set up these therapeutic
intervals it's typically based on a
single
single site
population where they've looked at the
response rates within that population
and they define a maximum threshold
above which you start to see an
increased prevalence of adverse events
and you would establish a minimum
threshold below which the majority of
patients don't seem to respond and then
the
the amount in between in that
and it's not based on necessarily a
percentage
but it's it's dependent on the
investigator the particular site when
they're looking that and they just
define this threshold and then um
other clinical sites either begin to
adopt these or they may
perform their own studies based on the
result to see how
how people respond but but realistically
you know they take these small
populations they they get
that that therapeutic interval
information and it's widely adopted
based on the single site study but it's
important to remember that these
reference intervals don't apply to each
individual or clinical situation so
while it's a population-based
therapeutic interval that may not
necessarily apply to a particular
individual
okay so what i've shown here is a list
of drugs that we typically monitor and
you'll notice that um chemotherapy drugs
are not necessarily included in there
the the classic example of where
therapeutic drug monitoring began was in
the anti-epileptic drugs
and then much of the work today has been
done in you know and over the last 20
years as an immunosuppressive drug
monitoring for transplantation
um but you'll see some of the other
things cardioactive drugs
in the anti-infective
drug area the aminoglycosides and
vancomycin are primarily the drugs that
are monitored although there is
increasing uh evidence around the the
utility of anti-fungal monitoring for
boriconazole and posaconazole uh
tricyclic antidepressants are monitored
uh primarily to avoid their the toxic
effects
and then we have you see some other
drugs analgesics hiv drugs and
antipsychotics among others
so when we get to chemotherapy
and monitoring chemotherapeutic drug
levels we'll we'll talk a little bit
about the case for
uh whether these drugs should be
monitored or not but but for the most
part they're not routinely monitored
there's a couple exceptions methotrexate
is a drug now that is
that has been monitored for some time
and then busulfan is a drug in select
in select centers where bone marrow
transplantation is is
occurring but outside of that there
really isn't a lot of therapeutic drug
monitoring for chemotherapy
and so the way these drugs are managed
is through traditional
dose
they try to account for variability
based on dosing to body surface area
rather than a typical milligram per
kilogram approach and so they will dose
this based on a maximum tolerated that's
dose that's been established um they
will then measure the clinical response
as in monitoring the tumor or look for
adverse events say hematologic toxicity
or something else
and then they choose their next steps do
they need to increase the dosage of the
drug or the intensity of the exposure do
they just need to add another reagent or
select a different
select a different chemotherapy pedic
agent and then this process is repeated
and again you'll you'll recognize that
as what we talked about just a few
minutes ago
as the the paradigm of titrate to
clinical effect and this follows it the
same way
so a problem with
uh this approach or oncology drugs in
general is that it's it's a complex it's
a complex disease
and
if you look at these comparative
efficacy rates you'll see um
some of the things we'll we have here i
have oncology drugs outlined you'll see
some of even the basic drugs like
analgesics cox2 inhibitors where maybe
it works for four out of every five
people and then you get to things like
ssri drugs for depression
and you're still only operating at a
clip of about two-thirds of the people
that respond to these drugs and then you
get to chemotherapeutics and maybe one
in four of the people respond to the
drugs based on based on this survey
and really why is that
why do we
have such a poor response rate and i
think
that could be broken down here so first
when you think about cancer if we it
would focus on that upper left hand part
of the slide we think about cancer it's
really a heterogeneous disease so just
because you have pancreatic cancer not
all pancreatic cancers are the same
same thing with all the lung cancers or
the gastrointes gastrointestinal cancers
each of the cancers is a little bit
different and and we know this because
of the great emphasis on the molecular
testing and genotyping of tumors to look
for chemosensitivity
so there's a lot of difference between
tumors that you may get between people
and then if you add that on top of it
this is the definition of cancer is
these out of control growth of cells
right you get this
alteration in your dna the cancer growth
cycle
becomes uh it's out of control growth
cycle and so the these
cancer cells are growing at a really
rapid rate and so you have this high
rate of mutation as well so the cancer
that you get on one day on day one may
not be the same cancer genetically
30 days later or 60 days later and and
actually it may be a mix of different
types of mutations in cancer cells and
some of those cells may be resistant and
so
that makes it very difficult to treat
and and that's something that
therapeutic drug monitoring or
pharmacokinetic
guided dosing is not going to fix
the other thing we have to think about
if you look at the other
upper hand right is the
is the nature of the drugs themselves
they're
a wide variety of drugs that have
a variety of pharmacokinetic
factors so they're absorbed at different
rates they are distributed some of them
are hydrophilic some of them are
hydrophobic some of them are metabolized
very differently and some of them are
actually pro drugs where the metabolite
is the chemotherapeutic agent and so all
of these things factor into that and
when we looked on our previous slide
that was really just lumping together
all chemotherapeutic agents and for some
folks maybe the response rate is
significantly higher and some folks uh
it's a little bit lower but there's a
lot of variability so you have the
variability in the tumor you couple with
that with the variability in the drugs
that are available and then you have to
think about the people themselves
there's a lot of variability in people
you think about
variability in
genotypes and phenotypes so as somebody
a fast metabolizer versus a slow
metabolizer
depending on
the physician practice or the treatment
paradigm different people will be on
different therapeutic regimens or
co-administered drugs maybe some of the
the patients will be on antidepressants
or
anxiety medication i i'm certain for me
that if i was diagnosed with cancer i
would have some anxiety and so those
drugs can implement some folks go to
natural products or nutraceuticals to
impact that as we as we discussed
earlier so you can have those drug drug
interactions you can have the genetic
variability between people and then you
have the non-genetic factors right
dietary factors what's the regional diet
for that person and do any of those
dietary factors play a role
in the pharmacokinetics of the drug
what about obesity morbidly obese
patients we look at pediatric patients
versus geriatric patients and they have
very different
typically organ functions and water body
water contents and all that variability
in people contributes to this
variability so now you have this massive
variability in the disease type or the
tumor type you have the massive
variability in the uh
the drug type and then you have
on top of that the the population
variability and with all that it can be
very complicated to treat the cancer and
and leads to these low response rates
and so because of that and
you know the the the oncologists and the
physicians that treat this cancer
they're looking for any tools that can
perhaps assist them in
in doing a more effective management so
they're looking for any tools that may
help them
before we go too far we also want to
talk about how do you get to that
maximum tolerated dose because i think
that's really important when you think
about the you know the
the ways that the cancer drugs are dosed
right so they're given at this maximum
tolerated dose and you think about it in
that um it's in this
modified 3x3 scheme so you start with
three patients here and you give them
the starting dose
and so this starting dose and that's
outlined in the study protocol and
they'll get this
lower end of the the dose and then and
no pharmacokinetic measurement so no
assessment typically of the the blood
concentration in terms of this this um
this consideration so you have the three
patients you look at the starting dose
and then you look for
grade three or grade four uh grade four
toxicity
seeing no toxicity then you do a dose
escalation scheme
well now you give it to the next three
patients and this will continue until
you get to
the the dose escalation level where you
see
um
one or more patients so that's one out
of three with a grade three or four
toxicity so let's say out of these three
patients one person had a dose limiting
toxicity as outlined in the study plan
well at that point we then repeat at the
same dose level
okay
and if at that dose level those three
patients
um
one of those patients exhibits the dose
limiting toxicity then you back down to
the previous level
if
at that previous level there is no dose
limiting toxicity that becomes the
recommended or maximum tolerated dose
but that is possible even if in that
upper level only two out of the six
patients demonstrated the dose limiting
toxicity the other four may not have had
that toxicity and so it's possible at
that point that that there the patients
that didn't demonstrate the toxicity
they're not really getting the maximum
tolerated dose so in other words
maybe half to two-thirds of the patients
aren't getting a true dose limiting
toxic
dose limiting toxicity or maximum
tolerated dose in other words they could
still handle more exposure of the drugs
so the other thing we want to look at is
this variability because we talked about
uh dosing to body surface area
and in the um
in the in the in the dosing to body
servicer the idea is that it really
comes from a scale up of animal studies
into human studies so the idea is that
you'll have
these
you'll have these
the patients
that you calculate the body surface area
and then you will
dose to that body surface area and that
will account for the variability but in
this slide i really like it it's from a
review in 2002 you'll see like for
something like cyclophosphamide this is
the histogram is representing if you
look at the y-axis it's the variability
in clearance which is a stand-in for
variability pharmacokinetic variability
and you'll see here that you have things
ranging anywhere from 25 variability in
clearance all the way up to
60 or even 70 percent variability this
is that that 70 variability is arena
teacan
meaning so this is the sn38 metabolite
so arena tican is a pro drug that's
metabolized to sn38 which has the the
chemotherapeutic effect but if you think
about that
what that really means is that you know
you're depending on the metabolism of
the patient to generate the drug that is
going to attack the tumor and if there's
variability it's going to be more
effective in some than others if there's
variability in their metabolism but the
other thing i wanted to point to here is
this line
this dashed line that you see it's a
little bit faint
but that's the variability across all
these populations are all these drugs in
this study for body surfacing in other
words
while the percent cv
of the pharmacokinetics or clearance
ranges anywhere from 25 to 70 percent
the body's surface area is pretty
constant at 15
so if you're if you're trying to
normalize the body surface area it's
really not doing a good job
of addressing all that variability and
so you can't just use dose and body
surface area to normalize across your
population
so we want to move into a couple of
a couple of examples that are that are
well documented in the literature we'll
start with both of these agents are are
drugs that have been around for some
time
the first one that we'll talk about is
five flurry uracil
this drug is a pyrimidine analog that's
used in many types of cancer
the the mechanism of action is
inhibition irreversible of the thymine
synthase enzyme and it's used in
combination with other drugs as the
basis for full fox uh
regimens or full theory regimens among
others bullfox now there are multiple
iterations of this i think it's now up
to six or or
i'm gonna stop at six but there may be a
seven or eight out there that i'm not
aware of but there are at least six full
fox regimens you know that where you're
using leukoborin and fluoro uracil and
oxaloplatin in in in various
combinations and and it is um
it is the 5-fluorouracil is metabolized
by an enzyme dihydrop pyrimidine
dehydrogenase or dpd and that has
significant inter-individual variability
so
when you get
or if you get five-flurry or so as a
patient there is going to be some
variability depending on the enzyme
activity of the dpd
the half-life is approximately uh 10 to
20 minutes of this agent
so i want to point to some studies that
that have taken a look at
pharmacokinetically guided dosing and
some of them are are relatively old um
this first study that i'll be pointing
to is a study that was done almost 15
years ago
by fedi and others as published in
clinical cancer research and this is a
multi-center randomized control trial
looking at about 120 patients and head
and neck cancer
the study design was such that patients
were randomized to either standard dose
regimen meaning uh you know
dose based on milligrams per body
surface area or a pharmacokinetically
guided regimen
so in this study the patients received
cisplatin followed by a bolus of five
flurry uracil and then a 96 hour
continuous five fluorinational infusion
so this is before the the full fox um
regimens or this one at least didn't use
full fox it focused on the the
five-floor uracil administration
and then they developed area under the
curved targets or drug exposure targets
based on the air under curve uh it was a
race
the relationship of air into the curve
for zero to 48 hours and then the air
into the curve for zero to 96 hours so
they did a pharmacokinetic assessment
and they were and they established these
these targets
and so the results are pretty
interesting they look both at the
efficacy
and the toxicity and if you'll look at
this
the dark
histogram box or right here
is
the standard dosing arm or milligrams
per kilogram
uh amounts are milligrams for body
surface area and then the white
box is for those that had
pharmacokinetically guided
adjustments and what you'll see here
is that uh in the first
backup two uh if you'll see the in the
first one they looked at the the
hematologic toxicity here and that's
looking at neutropenia or
thrombocytopenia and you'll see a
statistically significant reduction in
the patient group that received routine
tdm relative to those that did not then
if we move over to the middle where we
look at the mucositis toxicity again
significantly different between the uh
the standard arm and the
pharmacokinetically guided arm now if
you look at the digestive toxicity which
is the other grade three four toxicity
that in that case what we're really
looking at now you'll see that in the
tdm arm
it did have a slightly higher rate but
that really was not statistically
significant in their analysis so we
would say that those are statistically
equivalent and not different at all
so if we look at the response or the
efficacy and in this case what they're
testing and they're not testing for
difference they're testing for
equivalence so was there any difference
in the in the in the efficacy of the
drug and they looked at patients that
had a complete response
a partial response and then
the objective response which is a
combination of the complete and partial
responses
and what's interesting to point out is
that statistically these regimens were
equivalent in terms of efficacy so by
using pharmacokinetically guided therapy
there was a reduction in toxicity with
no appreciable impact on the efficacy
in other words they were able to
effectively treat the patients while
minimizing the toxicity
now if we move from head and neck cancer
into colorectal cancer there are a
series of studies by this gambling group
i'll present um only a handful of them
today but the first one we'll point to
here is a 1998 study which is a
multi-center trial not a randomized
control trial
but where they were look administering
leukovorum followed by an eight-hour
continuous infusion
the target range in this case was not an
area under the curve but at once steady
state has reached they were looking for
a blood concentration of between 2 000
and 3 000 micrograms per ml
okay
and so
having defined their target range they
were able to take a look at the number
of cycles necessary to
reach the optimal therapeutic level uh
they were able to look at the the um
how
how the patients responded relative to
the number of courses it took to reach
the the target level and you'll see that
the best response responders were able
to have their target level within one to
three courses now this is what's
particularly industry interesting i
think right here
which is based on the blood levels and
the target they had of 2000 to three
thousand
they found that um
most people were not overdosed only
about ten percent of the patients really
required lower doses of the drug where
almost eighty percent of the patients
are i guess a little over eighty percent
of the patients that required a higher
dose of the drug
another interesting finding is that the
folks that responded well their plasma
levels increased so while initially
there there may have been
a necessary dosage increase to receive
the the to achieve the therapeutic
target once that therapeutic target was
achieved and the patients were
responding to the cancer then the dose
had to be adjusted again to avoid
toxicity and they did find a correlation
between acute toxicity and levels
greater than three thousand uh that was
highly significant so again they found
that
many patients were underdosed and they
were able to avoid toxicity by keeping
the patients under that target of three
thousand micrograms per ml
jumping forward
a significant amount from from that
previous 1998 study to a 2008 study by
the by the same group this is a study
done in the journal of published in the
journal of clinical oncology and this
was a randomized control trial
incorporating pharmacokinetically guided
therapy as well as
the standard dosing regimen again and
this was with the full fox regiment i
believe and but what's interesting here
is you'll look at arm a
being the uh
arm a is the standard dosing
and arm b
is the pharmacokinetically guiding
dosing and what you'll see
is that uh you'll see a
patient's uh did better or had had an
improved clinical outcome in the
pharmacokinetically guided arm of the
study relative to the um to the
non-guided arm of the study
in some other work that um uh may have
been published later but the slide that
i have here is from there um from an
abstract that was submitted at
asco you'll see that this was another
phase two study uh using full fox where
there were um almost 120 uh patients um
with beta stack and colorant
metastatic colorectal cancer
and then about 40 patients that had
that were given in the body surface area
group so
about a three to one ratio or
of patients that were getting
pharmacokinetically guided therapy
relative to
standard dosing and but what was
interesting is the finding so when you
look at the toxicity of the group
arm a being the standard dose and arm b
being the the pk guided nose you'll find
that you see significant reductions in
diarrhea
mucositis
and
but not hematologic toxicity so where
you saw a reduction in the diarrhea and
mucositis but no reduction in the
hemologic toxicity
uh so there was some um uh uh reduction
in the toxicities now if we look at the
response you'll see the the positive uh
well let's look at the arm and said arm
a the standard dosing you'll see that
the positive response was about 46
percent
and the non-responders 40 54
so about a 50 50 mix of responders and
non-responders
and then if you look at the pk guided
arm you'll see a 70 positive response
rate relative to a 30
uh non-response rate so based on this
data what you're looking at is you see
reduction in toxicity and in addition to
an improvement in response rate and then
we have the survival data which shows in
progression free survival of 10 months
for standard dosing relative to six uh
16 months in pk guided dosing or if we
look at the median and this is median
progression free survival and median
overall survival
in these groups you saw a median of 22
months for standard dosing versus 28
months so again this is data that
implies that
the pharmacokinetic guided dosing does
give some benefits to patients
another study i just want to touch on
this is again from uh from an asco
symposium this is out of the the one
strip group from 2010 and this was
looking at plasma samples from patients
receiving full fox6 over 44 to 48 hours
for for adjuvant and metastatic
treatment of colorectal cancer
and they were looking
at an immunoassay
called ondos that was measuring
5-fluorouracil
the thing that i want to point out from
this study is really the the dose
narrowing so we've shown that if you're
able to establish this target
therapeutic interval you'll see
that in during the first cycle of
treatment
where the blue box
is the
is the the therapeutic target there's
really almost no one
in the therapeutic target and you see
this extremely wide spread
of values all
over the area under the curve
contrast that with the fourth cycle as
you as you pull the data and using this
pharmacokinetic data to be able to
modify the dose and you'll see by the
fourth cycle many more patients are uh
are are within or in the fringes of the
of the therapeutic target uh and this
may be highlighted a little bit better
if we show the the table so you can see
the numeric data where you'll see in
sample one or in the first cycle
you'll see our target of 20 to 24 for
auc and you'll see that only two percent
of patients are in that narrow box and
then another 50 percent of patients
are are in the the french area of this
so
if you compare that with sample four
where you now have you've gone from
three percent to almost forty percent of
patients in that narrow therapeutic
target and then you have an additional
almost 50 in the fringe for a total of
um
50 47
80 almost
um 85
little over 85
so you have much higher in this in this
therapeutic target window and i think
that
is evidence that using this
pharmacokinetically guided data you can
you can and if you're willing to jump in
and make the dose adjustments that you
can certainly
drive toward a therapeutic target
interval
and the last study i wanted to to show
on five flurry uracil
is a pharmacoeconomic study so this is
looking at cost-effectiveness of uh
pharmacokinetics
and so this is somebody
doing modeling based on the data some of
the data that i already showed and some
other studies that were out there where
they're looking at body surface area
guided
relative to pharmacokinetically guided
full fox regimens in metastatic
colorectal cancer
and this is really just an empiric um uh
representation of the model so they're
looking at the administration of these
regimens and then
what second line
treatment is needed once the disease
progresses and then ultimately looking
at death as the end point
as they calculate the quality
adjusted life years
and what they found was that as they
compared these
groups they did they took into account
all the different types of adverse
events and and the progression free
survival and overall survival and what
they found here is uh an incremental
difference of or an increase for pk
guided full fox therapy of about one
half a little over one half point five
seven three quality adjusted life years
with an incremental cost of thirteen
thousand dollars uh when they get to the
incremental cost of uh effectiveness
rate that's where they were seeing about
per quality life quality adjusted life
here they were really seeing
about 23 000 maybe a little less than
that
where you do it does cost more
to administer the pk guided full fox
therapy especially if patients are
living longer that means they're going
to
um
they're going to have additional cycles
of therapy amended if you remember back
to the the data we showed previously
many of those patients that are having
pharmacokinetically guided therapy
require dosage increases which are going
to cost more in terms of the first-line
chemotherapy but you do see a reduction
in second-line chemotherapy because it's
a slower to progression
and then the last analysis they did was
looked at this relative to a cost
effectiveness acceptability curve and
finding that the the 22 000 is very
close to the midpoint of this cost
effect is a
cost effectiveness acceptability curve
and so they found that
depending on you know what the
willingness to pay is certainly this
this gets um you know the willingness to
pay is at forty thousand dollars then um
it's certainly uh possible that you know
a an increase of an incremental increase
of twenty two to twenty three thousand
dollars uh certainly fits within that
and people are likely to to adopt that
type of um
thing
okay
uh we'll shift gears a little bit and
move from um uh the solid tumors and
five flurry uracil into imatinib
so i'm at nib um you know there's
there's there's uh additional interest
that's being generated in other tyrosine
kinase inhibitors but but we'll focus on
imatinib which is a a tki that's used in
treatment of cml or or gastrointestinal
stromal tumors
for for cml this the drug targets the
bcr able
tyrosine kinase and just it target
targets the c kit
it's primarily metabolized by c sip
three three a four and five which means
there's a high degree of pharmacokinetic
variability between individuals and the
half-life is is significantly longer so
it can be given as once daily dosing and
can be given as outpatient chemotherapy
in some cases and anytime you're giving
somebody a pill to take home now you're
starting to bring into the you're
bringing into the equation this issue of
compliance are people really taking
their medication the way that they're
supposed to
so when we when we're um
assessing the cml response to therapy
because the the the response to magnum
and cmls i'm sorry not because but the
response to imatinib in cml is followed
through looking at transcript levels of
bcr able and it's
it's expressed as a log reduction from a
standardized value
and there are um
three
different levels we'll we'll talk about
which would be a two log reduction would
be called a complete cytogenetic
response a three log reduction in
transcripts is the major molecular
response which is three log reduction
and if the transcripts become
undetectable that would be categorized a
complete molecular response the major
objective of the therapy is the two law
the two log reduction in uh transcript
because that's associated with prolonged
survival
and we can demonstrate that in um this
you'll see it and
it's a little bit different of a figure
this is from a jco paper in 2012 but
you'll see the blue line is the three if
if the the three months transcript ratio
is less than less than
or equal to 0.61 percent you can see the
um the insolence incidence of a complete
molecular response whereas if you don't
get to that
uh transcript ratio three months
transcript ratio
of 0.61 or less your your chance of
getting to complete molecular responses
much lower and what that data really uh
emphasizes it's it's important not just
to get to the lower transcript ratio but
to do so quickly and if you want to do
it quickly that means you have to make
sure that you're you're at an effective
dose
of the um of the chemotherapy
once the the leukemia is discovered and
you also do you want to get and you want
to get there quickly
and make sure that people are in here
adhering
this slide is a little bit busy but i
wanted to to put together this
information and show a couple things
we'll start actually in the the upper
right hand corner of the slide and and
in this slide what it's demonstrating is
the distribution of um
of uh
the the concentration of imatinib uh
based on different doses so the
different colors correspond to different
dosages ranging from less than 300
milligrams uh to more than 400
milligrams and and it's important to
point out at this stage that in this
case it's not really dosing to body
surface area the drug is being dosed at
a flat rate so the standard it's being
given at a standard dose of 400
or 300 or 600 milligrams
but when you look at that the different
dosing you can see that only about half
of the patients
are at a
concentration a steady state constant
trough concentration of 1 000 nanograms
per ml or less
so the question is why is that
important well if you look at this study
this is from a review
from the takahashi
paper listed here you'll see that
they've looked at a bunch of different
studies and in each case they're looking
at the imatinib trough concentration
you'll see concentrations here of 900 a
thousand just shy of a thousand 999
just a little over one thousand and in
each of these cases with the exception
of
these two studies by forest and whitmer
all the other ones show a correlation of
the trough concentration with response
whether that's complete cytogenetic
response or major molecular response
and if you look at this figure in the
bottom right hand corner you'll see that
in looking at the distribution here
you'll see that uh in this grouping of
patients where they measure the trough
concentration in the grouping of
patients that have a trough
concentration greater than one thousand
and two nanograms per ml
almost 75 percent of them achieved major
molecular response whereas the patients
with less
than one thousand and two nanograms per
milliliter had a major molecular
response in only in just under 60
percent of the cases so all of these
imply again that the
having a trough concentration of
imatinib greater than a thousand
nanograms per ml is important is an
important predictor of treatment success
perhaps more important than the dose
that you actually take
we want to look a little bit at
adherence which is going to be related
to the blood concentration right because
if you're not taking the drug it's not
going to get into your your bloodstream
this is an interesting study from 2010
where they measured patient adherence by
a couple of different ways the first way
was pill counting and that's something
that's been around for a long time the
other way to monitor this is something
called mems it's a it's a medication
event monitoring system and it's a
really interesting
device that has a radio frequency tag in
the in the top of the cap and what it
does is it records every time you open
the bottle
so you could open the bottle one time
pour out 30 pills
put the top back on and take it back
they'll count your pills and it will
look like after a month you've taken all
the pills but the
but the physician will be able to know
that well you didn't open that bottle 30
times so you're clearly not taking it
once a day therefore you're
non-compliant or not adhering and so in
this study they the the investigators
told the patients about pill counting
but they didn't tell them about the
men's cap and so they were able to have
an objective measure of whether the
patients were
actually adherent to the regiment or not
and to the and the
the degree to which they were adherent
um were they 90 adherent 75 percent
adherent 50 adherent and then they were
looking at the the response to the
medication by measuring the bcr enabled
transcripts and then they did some other
they did some other measures as well in
terms of looking at genetic mutations
now here's what's interesting if we look
at the top
category here of adherence the blue line
is an adherence of greater than 90
percent
the yellow line is an adherence of less
than 90 percent and so if you look in
panel number one
you'll see that there's a significantly
higher
chance of major molecular response if
you're 90 adherence versus um
and remember that's a three log
reduction versus the uh those that were
less than 90 adherent and remember
that's a combination of anybody who's 88
percent adherent or two percent adherent
so so that's that's a a large amount to
to lump into one thing if we go to the
middle which is a four-fold which is a
four-long reduction so that we have the
three log reduction which is major
molecular response we have a four log
reduction which is the um sort of the
you know the next step down and then we
see in the bottom line which is if
you're less than 90 adherent you have
almost no chance of complete uh complete
response
one other thing to note from this study
is looking at the concentration right
the imatinib plasma level so even though
it wasn't an endpoint of the study in
terms of informing the decisions
these patients did have blood drawn and
they measured the trough concentrations
and if you look at the major molecular
response
and the plasma level what do you see
those that
had a plasma level of less than one
microgram per mil which is a thousand
nanograms per ml had a response of 60
whereas those with greater than one had
a response of
had 83 percent
if we go to the complete
molecular response you'll see those with
a plasma level of less than a thousand
was 23 percent whereas those um that had
a plasma level of greater than a
thousand nanograms per ml or one
microgram per ml had a um
had a response of i'm sorry a complete
molecular response of uh 44
so clearly there's something associated
with this trough concentration that
seems to be a reasonable cut-off
so if we shift gears from leukemia and
go into the gastrointestinal stroble
tumors this is an interesting study that
was done in 2009 looking at patients
randomly uh assigned to receive imatinib
of 400 milligrams per se versus 600
milligrams daily uh and then in a subset
of these patients they looked in about
70 of them they looked at pk data they
looked at the plasma levels and they
looked at the relationship between
exposure and clinical outcome but they
did it in a way where they didn't do it
in a continuous way they they grouped
the patients into quartiles and then
they looked at the response rate plus
stable disease they looked at time to
progression and then they also did some
analysis looking at the the kit
genotyping versus favorable mutations
versus unfavorable unfavorable mutations
so this is a really interesting slide
from the paper i think which
demonstrates so that the patient's
getting
400 milligram doses are in the yellow
and the 600 milligram doses are getting
the are the blue labels and you'll look
at each of the quartiles
you'll see that there are some for each
dose right even in quartile one the
lowest
concentration you still see some that
are getting the highest dose right
and in the quartile four you see some
that are getting the lower dose and this
clearly demonstrates that there's a lot
of pharmacokinetic variability
associated with this drug whether that's
due to adherence whether that's due to
pharmacokinetic variability between the
individuals
there's still a lot of that variability
there
the other thing that is really
interesting to note if i can uh draw
this line here you'll see at that cutoff
of the quartile
that's right around
the 1000 it's a little bit higher
but that's that the the dividing line
from quartile one from the rest of the
group
is right around a thousand or a little
bit higher and that's going to be
significant when you look at the data
analysis
so let's look at
our quartile one versus quartile three
and four so if we look at line 1
of this table
so the gray up here this is looking at
all patients so it's not separating out
any mutations and what you'll find is
that the
when you're looking at the overall
response you'll find a response rate of
about 67 percent in quartile one whereas
quartiles
two three and four
in quartiles two and three you have uh
the middle 50 percent
you have an 81 response rate and you
have an 84 response rate in the highest
quartile
all right now if we look at those with
exon 11 mutations which makes them more
sensitive to the imatinib therapy you'll
see that in the lowest quartile we have
a response rate of about
that number is small but it looks like
right around 67 percent and now if you
look in the highest quartiles you'll see
in quartiles two three and four we have
a hundred percent uh rate when you
consider all the outcomes the partial
response stable disease and complete
response
now if we look at the
exon 9 mutations which we could consider
more resistant to the treatment you'll
see the quartile one
is a 67 response rate when you consider
stable disease plus complete and partial
response quartile two and three has a
similar response rate to quartile one
but in the highest quartile
um
the you see a hundred percent response
rate with an n of one so i'm not willing
to draw any conclusions to say if you
have the exon 9 mutation in kit that
you're going to do better if you have
the highest uh imatinib concentrations
but it does um maybe beg the question as
to whether that should be investigated
or not
but clearly again coming back to that
quartile one and the poorer response
rates again that sort of points to this
trough concentration of a thousand
nanograms per mill as being a
a potential therapeutic target that we
should pay attention to
and here if we look at again that the
progression fee free survival relatives
to time since start of treatment and
you'll see the quartile one uh quartiles
two three and four seem to be pretty
well similar but it the quartile one uh
patients definitely do worse and those
would be the patients with trough levels
less
than one nanogram per ml
so we'll move to the uh this last set of
studies that i'll talk about today which
is um
there is first a population
pharmacokinetic study done in 2014 so
earlier this year
or it was published earlier this year
and this was just taking a group of
patients that were getting a standard
dose of 400 milligrams
of
of imatinib and then looking at the
the
the trough concentrations and then
looking at clinical events relative to
those trough concentrations and the the
thing i point out in this this is just a
plot of the distribution and you'll see
again that there are many many patients
at this dose of 400 nanograms per ml i
mean sorry 400 milligrams that have a
trough concentration of less than 1 000
nanograms per ml the median would
actually be right around which is the
dark line here is at about 800 nanograms
per mil
and so you can see this this plot here
if we shift it a little bit now this is
doing on the population basis with the
variability you'll you'll follow the
dashed lines and you it's clear that
there is a response in these
investigators study where you see an
increase in probability of improved
outcome which is uh cytogenetic response
uh the molecular response so those the
the probability of those types of
responses increase increases with
increased
uh trough concentration uh bimatinib and
then you'll see that there is an
increase this lowest one is the increase
in adverse events probability of adverse
events and that probability does also
increase with dose although it would
appear that it increases at a lower rate
than does either probability of
molecular uh major molecular response or
cytogenetic complete cytogenetic
response so especially if you're looking
at this increasing the plasma
concentration or the trough
concentration of matin significantly
increases your chance of a major
molecular response while much less
increasing your chance of adverse events
based on this plot
and so based on those findings the same
group and this is a paper that is just
recently electronically available it's
it's epub
ahead of print i have the reference here
at the bottom of the slide and this is
where they went to do a randomized
control trial to build on that
pharmacokinetic work so based on this
work they determined to
with a small number of patients only 56
but they randomized to what they would
call um
the rescue tdm group so this is a group
that got standard treatment but if the
patients want they were still getting
the blood concentrations measured and if
the patients were doing poorly they had
the ability to go back in and access
that that um the blood concentration
data and make dosage adjustments based
on that and then they had uh the other
half of the patients that were allocated
to a routine tdm which means that uh
during this they they would get the the
semen or the trough concentration result
along with a dosage recommendation and
so the dosage recommendations were not
um strictly a strict pharmacokinetic
guidance what they were would be they
separated the pan
patients into bins so if you were close
to the therapeutic target you might
increase the dose by 25
if you were further below you would
increase the dose by 50
and if you were you know in the lowest
tier they might suggest that you
increase the you know that you would
double the dose of imatinib that the
patient would receive
and so but they they in each case
whether it's rescue tdm or routine tdm
they would give the patie the physicians
not only the result but a dosage
recommendation
and in evaluating the data what they
found was
not
a lot of value right if you look at just
the routine routine tdm versus the
rescue tdm you don't see any significant
differences it doesn't seem to
demonstrate the value
which puzzled the investigators and they
went in to do a little additional
digging and what they found was that in
many cases
even though they gave dozens
recommendations those dosage
recommendations were not followed so if
you go into the retaining routine tdm
which is the figure on the right hand
side you'll find that if they when they
look at the subgroup analysis you're
getting the solid black line up here
these are patients who follow the
protocol and then the in the dashed line
down here these were patients who did
get the tdm results but the physicians
for whatever reason did not make the
dosage adjustment as
uh recommended by the protocol or maybe
they made a dosage adjustment but just
not the full amount but in either case
if if you get if you look at and this is
a very small number of patients so again
it's hard to make a definitive
statistical um conclusion from this but
you'll see again is it suggests that if
the patients or the physicians followed
the protocol according to the blood
level monitoring of the drug those
patients fared better than those who did
not
follow the protocol
so based on this data is there a
rational way to use this data what's
what's what's the best way to approach
this you know because
you have to have some guidance and how
do you use this relative to a lot of the
data that's out there in terms of
genotyping because that in terms of
companion diagnostics that's where a lot
of the emphasis is today and i don't
think that it's competing priorities i
think really that this is an area where
there could be a lot of complementary
value by using both genetic testing and
pharmacokinetic
assessment
so this is a really nice figure that i
wish i had done but
this guy uh
judson in clinical cancer research
published this a couple years ago and i
think it's fabulous so he looks at it
starts with diagnosis of advanced gist
and this can be based on
molecular testing or tumor marker
testing or clinical evaluation but once
you determine that the patient has
the the
the disease then you go in to make an
assessment of whether or not they have a
favorable genotype
in this case we're looking at the kit
genotype so as we mentioned the you if
you look at the unfavorable genotype
if you have the most resistant genotype
the exon 9 molecular test you don't
we're not going to mess with the
pharmacokinetic testing we're going to
go to the absolute maximum dose which is
800 nanograms
i'm sorry 800 milligrams daily
now
if you have an unfavorable genotype
but it's wild type or
resistant genotype
and you have to go in a different
direction then perhaps they would go
with a different
tyrosine kinase inhibitor so again it
doesn't help you with the dose it tells
you select a different therapy
now if
the you diagnose somebody with the tumor
and they find the mutation analysis that
shows a favorable genotype then it
suggests let's start with the magnet
here's where the complementary part
takes place
now you know that the tumor should be
sensitive to the drug so now let's make
sure that the appropriate exposure is
taking place
by doing that we do that with blood
level monitoring and we do a response
assessment so we have the therapeutic
drug monitoring and we have the response
assessment three months or sooner and
then we repeat the pk study
down the line so this is this would be a
continuous cycle now if we have the
blood level data we have the response
assessment if we're seeing a poor
responsive progression then perhaps and
we have a low trough level meaning
minimal or not sufficient exposure to
the magnet then you can increase the
dose
if on the other hand you have um
a
a poor response but your blood level is
within the target range then perhaps
it's time to change to a new agent such
as cement
if you have a good response and an
adequate blood level then you continue
if you have a good response and but you
have a low trough level you still have
the opportunity to increase that
imatinib and perhaps get to a complete
cytogenetic response a little bit more
rapidly and then you would continue to
cycle this until you receive the
until you achieve the cmr or stable
disease and as long as they're on the
mating you would continue the the pk
study to make sure that things haven't
changed and that that change can mean uh
addition of a additional drug or
nutraceutical that will change the
metabolism it could just be somebody who
thinks they're feeling good and would
stop taking the drug regardless of the
reason you'll want to make sure that if
this is a disease the patient is going
to live with for an extended period of
time you want to make sure that they're
taking the medicine the way that they're
supposed to
and so this fits into a bigger idea
which is you know i don't think it just
fits four
imatinib or four or five floor uracil
there's a way that we can use uh this
these tools available to us to take a
comprehensive approach to
precision medicine or precision
chemotherapeutics so the genetic testing
is vital in finding chemo sensitivity
characterizing the tumor and trying to
pick the exact right drug and then we
want to either using biomarkers of
response or drug levels
and either one or both we find a way to
to measure the ongoing response for the
non-genetic factors and make sure that
we're optimizing that therapy and if we
need to make modifications to either the
dose or change the drug we can do that
faster by using uh these these tools and
not waiting just for assessment of
imaging or looking for hematologic or
other types of toxicities we can really
make these assessments earlier which
allow us to modify the dosage earlier if
needed
uh and with that i'm happy to take any
questions with my time left
um
so i do have uh some questions that i
pulled up here uh this is the um
the first question it looks like from
barbara stout which says what's a
typical toxic effect that is looked for
during the
the determination of maximum tolerated
dose and i would say that typically it
really is dependent a little bit on the
um
on
what the drug is and what its
clinical effects are but we we
demonstrated some of these here which
typically you know we're following these
patients looking for hematologic
toxicities or gi toxicities and then
there may be some other toxicities that
go along with it uh but but you know
definitely hematologic and gi toxicity
um are two of the two of the big ones
um
this looks like it's a question from
maggie arose
it says what what are the factors that
are assessed
in the pk arm of those studies
so in the pk arm of the studies they're
they're assessing and again this depends
on the type of tumor and the type of
drug so when they're assessing that
they're looking at the drug exposure so
in many cases it's not a single time
point but they're assessing the
pharmacokinetics exposure by the area
under the curve and then in many cases
in these pk studies they are looking at
confounding factors such as potential
drug drug interactions or genotypes
once they've assessed that
pharmacokinetic exposure then again
they're looking at toxicities which is a
little bit
relative to the question that i just
answered for barbara and they're looking
at these toxicities but then they're
also looking at the the
the drug advocacy which in this case
would be uh in the case of chemotherapy
would be that bcr able uh transcripts in
some cases it may be looking at tumor
size or additional biopsies and things
like that so i think it depends on the
type of tumor
but you're looking at
whatever it is in that particular
disease relative to that particular drug
and its associated toxicities you're
looking at both biomarkers or or
clinical assessment of toxicity as well
as efficacy of the drug and then looking
at that exposure and what may impact
that that pharmacokinetic exposure
uh let's see
uh this is another question from barbara
stout
which asks uh with the men's case how do
they account for the frequent use of
weekly and monthly pill box that many
folks use
um so in this case i i think that they
get i have not been involved you know up
front i haven't been involved in
any of these mem studies directly so my
understanding is that
if i'm if i'm understanding your
question correctly that they would
they would have a special container so
they wouldn't be able to use the the
same pill boxes that they use
uh that would contain their utter other
medications so for the imatinib they
would have a container that only has
imatinib and wouldn't be impacted by any
statins or antidepressants ending
anxiety drugs or vitamins or anything
else that they take so they would have a
separate pill box dedicated only for
that and i've seen them do that with
imatinib and then this is all also
frequently used for adherent studies in
psychoactive drugs as well
so so that's that's how they would they
would separate that out from all the
other pills that the patients are taking
um
the this question is from i apologize if
i if i don't get your first name
correctly it's emer sheridan from from
the university of huddersfield
and the question they ask is don't you
think this is exactly what pharmacists
should be doing
and i would say
definitely pharmacists should be
involved i think that you know what
we're working toward within our
institution is the ability to um a
stability to work with pharmacists so we
think that the lab and pharmacists
should be working together to
give this consultative and supportive
surface
to the uh to the oncologist treating the
patient so really i don't think
pharmacists should be doing it on their
own although i will say pharmacists in
our institution are doing this with some
of the anti-fungal drug monitoring
aminoglycoside monitoring and other
drugs and we support them in that by
helping them
understand
the limitations of the testing the the
analytic variability versus the biologic
variability but i really think it's not
just pharmacists or just lab or just
oncologists i think for this to be
successful it's really um it takes a
confluence of people where you have the
oncologist working with the molecular
pathologist working with the pharmacist
working with uh the laboratory and and
taking this multidisciplinary
disciplinary approach and if if that's
done in a in a truly flat way i think
that you can utilize these tools to
affect
better outcomes but
it has it has to happen like that and
and we have to have the tools to be able
to support it right now many of the
healthcare information systems are so
siloed and not integrated with these
different pieces of information it's
difficult to pull everything together so
i think that that can be problematic
but yes pharmacists should absolutely be
involved in this process
uh this is a question from ryan matsuda
at the university of nebraska-lincoln i
went to the university of
nebraska-lincoln so
i'm glad you're on the
on the call here
um so it says how about the formulation
type and improving patient compliance
and adherence and that's absolutely uh
certainly a factor but that becomes more
of a
that becomes more of a
variability issue i'm sorry a behavioral
issue i don't know why i said
variability that becomes a behavioral
issue because now you're talking about
you know some people prefer to take
pills some people absolutely don't want
to take pills and so
the formulation type i'm sure plays a
role in that
you know if they can get to where you
can get a matinee by a patch that you
would put on
you know once a a day or week like they
can do with adh medications or pain
medications uh but there's a lot of work
that would need to be done in that and
i'm not aware that that work at least
nothing that i've seen
published on this but that doesn't mean
it's not underway but but certainly you
know formulation could be a
consideration
but then you also have to take that into
account in terms of the drug exposure so
the you know the pharmacokinetics will
vary relative to the formulation and
that's important to consider too
um
this is a second question
um
from
uh
emir sheridan
um
this is a question about point of care
testing i'm gonna encourage you uh if
you would take down my email address
and um this is probably a question that
would
take a lot longer to answer than over a
video camera but i'd be happy to
correspond with you via email or um by
telephone to discuss this point of care
testing so uh happy that tap would you
engage in that topic um but just send me
an email and we'll coordinate in an
offline um
an offline
uh conversation about them
and oh
say hello to dave and everyone else back
at university of nebraska to ryan
um so i think that's all the questions
we have we're out of the questions and
it looks like my time is over so
i appreciate your attention uh for
for the webinar thank you